berlin accueille ce dimanche une
conférence internationale visant à
trouver une issue au conflit qui déchire
la libye et ainsi éviter une escalade
des tensions au sahel et en afrique du
nord
cette tentative de faire cesser les
hostilités a commencé le 8 janvier à
l'occasion de la rencontre entre le
président russe vladimir poutine et son
homologue turc recep tayyip erdogan
alors qu'il inaugurait conjointement le
gazoduc nord stream
j'insiste particulièrement sur l'appel
que les présidents poutine et erdogan
ont adressé à toi j'ai parties libyennes
la cessation immédiate des hostilités un
cessez le feu
à minuit le dimanche 2 janvier c'est à
dire dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
s'en est suivi un véritable marathon
diplomatique où moscou a joué un rôle
clé l'admirent poutine à d'abord
accueilli un gala merkel au kremlin le
11 janvier pour discuter de la situation
en libye
c'est d'ailleurs à cette occasion que la
tenue de cette conférence de berlin
s'est véritablement dessinée
deux jours plus tard les deux principaux
protagonistes du conflit libyen se
déplaçait à moscou sous l'égide des
ministres russe et turc des affaires
étrangères et de la défense
des discussions qui malgré un certain
progrès n'ont pas abouti à la signature
de l'accord rallye five stars ayant en
effet quitté la russie sans avoir
paraphé le document final une décision
qui n'a pas plu du côté de la turquie
alliée du gouvernement d'union nationale
de fayez elle sa rage en conséquence le
président erdogan a confirmé l'envoi de
troupes sur place
nous envoyons notre on en libye pour
assurer la survie et la stabilité du
gouvernement légitime
sachant que la sécurité de la turquie
commence en dehors de ses frontières
nous continuerons de mobiliser toutes
nos installations politiques et
commerciales humanitaire diplomatique et
militaire pour la stabilité géographique
au sud de la turquie
mais tandis que l'union européenne
accusant kara d'ingérence le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères constate
que ce sont les diplomaties russe et
turc qui tente de recoller les morceaux
en libye après l'intervention de
l'alliance atlantique de 2011 qui a
plongé le pays dans le chaos
l'état libyen a été bombardé par l'otan
en 2011 et nous sommes toujours
confrontés aux conséquences de cette
intervention illégale et criminelle
en premier lieu le peuple libyen
plusieurs pays seront représentés à
l'occasion de cette conférence de berlin
la russie à la turquie donc mais aussi
la france l'italie les états unis la
chine les émirats arabes unis ou encore
certains pays limitrophes de la libye
comme l'algérie et l'egypte
khalifa haftar est fayez elle sa rage
ont également confirmé leur venue
place donc à la diplomatie ce dimanche à
berlin avec pour objectif de rendre le
cessez-le-feu durable sur le terrain et
d'éviter que la libye ne se transforme
en 2e série
[Musique]